welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
voss and batman unburied is an amazing
narrative podcast series available on
spotify's out now this video was
sponsored by spotify whom we had
partnered with to break down this first
episode of the series in which we find
bruce wayne as a forensic pathologist
voiced by winston duke as he hunts the
harvester voiced by sam whitwer whom you
may know as the haunting voice of maul
on the star wars animated series i mean
it's not every day we try to break down
an audio podcast here on new rock stars
but i think when you listen to this
you'll find this batman mystery to be as
rich and as twisted as any other so
episode one opens with audio reports in
the counties of new rotterdam ford
office and multiple homicides in gotham
city proverb all the work of a killer
some are calling the gotham harvester
who has taken organs from his victims
yes new rotterdam and fort dolphins are
both aliases for gotham city in the
comics knew rotterdam being its original
dutch name but then the station changes
to a talk radio dj city-wide curfew in
effect as of a few hours ago but if
you're anything like me
you're wide awake and wired
so if you're still with me out there
shivering in this unseasonable cold i'll
keep it warm for you here because this
is summer gleason and you are listening
to the sound of summer on w-i-b-s
yes summer gleason is a wgob news
reporter from batman the animated series
she mentions the unseasonable cold
reflecting bruce's job in the morgue of
this hospital and how he later compares
his workplace to the icy depths of hell
then on to that hospital where dr bruce
wayne performs an autopsy on a jane doe
one of the harvester's victims alongside
kell his new morgue attendant oh god
she's warm
is this your first
second but um
my last one was not like this yeah kell
doesn't get into it here but it does
sound like she might have a hidden past
that she's not disclosing like she's
only been around one dead body before
and now she works as a morgue attendant
anyway while bruce analyzes the body is
kel read the police report construction
crew found her hanging from a crane in
tri-corner yards
starting physical exam
she was tied up quote
vitruvian man pose yes the vitruvian man
was leonardo da vinci's sketch that
showed the human form splayed out which
was meant to demonstrate the ratio of
the limbs of the human body now fun fact
davinci gave that man and the sketching
his own face the face of the artist all
of this gives us insight into the
harvester's academic mind and his
religious appreciation for intelligent
design bruce uses his unusual method of
empathizing with the deceased i am his
victim
he selected me
why now ironically this method ends up
becoming bruce's actual question as he
himself becomes a literal victim of the
harvester i am chosen
i have something to give they realized
that the harvester already washed this
body he washed her feet her legs he
cares for us
us yes bruce switches to first person
plural pronouns perhaps a sign for him
considering himself a separate entity
than the victim but still someone cared
for alongside her by the harvester and
also as we learn all of this is really a
collective understanding of service
coming from jesus washing the disciples
feet which bruce starts a hint at here
i'm a church
a church he wandered into at random the
biblical allusions continue when the
harvester sneaks in to attack bruce here
slicing his side and muttering into his
ear
i am a man and a woman's from my rib
and i am a man and a man
[Music]
yes i am man woman is from my rib
referencing the book of genesis when god
crafted e from adam's rib but then the
harvester mixes his illusions by
referencing egyptian mythology where
upon death one's heart is weighed on
scales by anubis against the weight of a
feather before he leaves the harvester
cuts a piece of the victim's brain and
places it on bruce's tongue so that he
can taste her fear now later while in
recovery bruce tells detective teague he
was wearing a mask
like one of those paramilitary wannabes
of balaclava army surplus kind of thing
yes the image we get in our heads evokes
the riddler in the recent matt reeves
batman who also suited up an army
surplus mask but his parents thomas and
martha wayne arrive still alive voiced
here by lance redick and talks to
lingadoya thomas tells his son which
organ did he take
you shouldn't be thinking about this
come on he took something i know it took
something
it was the pancreas yes the pancreas
produces insulin which helps control
blood sugar which would be interesting
then the harvester would also make bruce
taste the victim's amygdala giving him
something to taste but crippling his
ability to digest it thomas scolds bruce
for performing 300 autopsies so far this
year well over the 250 annually allowed
by one doctor under state law making
bruce morbidly obsessed i love the
choice by the way to make the world's
greatest detective a medical expert akin
to sherlock holmes training being in the
field of medicine then on to another
radio segment welcome to the grey ghost
radio hour yes gray ghost was a
fictional hero from bruce's childhood in
the animated series voiced by adam west
grey ghost was a vigilante who like
zorro inspired bruce to become batman
bruce takes mandatory therapy sessions
with dr hunter voiced by john reese
davis who uses hypnosis inducing
light-based equipment thought is
electrochemical impulse passed through
wrinkled flesh and to think even the
simplest thing to retrieve even the
simplest memory
is to capture lightning in a
bottle do not be surprised if dr hunter
might have a more duplicitous agenda
which even hints at here in the scene
which one is it by the way are you a
doctor or a hunter
a bit of both i'm afraid then hunter
asks sexually active
you want to know if i'm into leather
everything is about sex except sex
leather a possible nod to bruce's
relationship with selena kyle known for
her leather attire then hunter says just
say whatever comes naturally just shoot
from the hip shoot from
i don't like that term
why
i don't like guns
oh or figures of speech it would appear
all right
any particular reason for your aversion
to guns
bruce
i
just
i've um just seen what guns do to a body
yes the sound of bats creep into bruce's
mind as he thinks about guns yet again
his parents are still alive here bruce
talks here about living in thomas shadow
and every time he walks down to visit it
must feel like he's walking into frozen
over hell yes again frozen over hell an
image from dante's inferno in which the
bottommost ninth circle of hell is
frozen over later on at his home martha
tries to set him up you know who i saw
at the community center that reporter
woman um
you went to college with her
victoria vicki
vale yes vicki vale of course batman's
love interest and reporter from the
comics but martha spills her drink on
her shirt and while cleaning it she
breaks her pearl necklace
[Music]
bruce
are you okay
they're just girls another odd moment
with bat sounds seeming to echo an
alternate life where of course famously
martha's pearl necklace was broken when
she and thomas were murdered and in the
midst of this hallucinatory state the
harvester calls bruce and bruce asks the
killer why he washes the bodies jesus
washing the disciples
oh
you sir have been to church
very good
if i then your lord and teacher have
washed your feet
you also ought to wash one another's
feet yes he quotes john 13 14 the story
of jesus washing the feet of the
disciples of the last supper which is a
ritual still practiced in holy week
services the harvester reveals that he
already left in bruce's freezer a
surprise it's half
half
of every morning oh no
oh my god don't look some ancient
cultures
uh if you
uh ate
of a person
uh
you could really know them you could
become them
i'm a martyr
or i will be but
i'm not christ
uh sometimes
uh
sometimes
i i think i might
be the other one yes the other one half
this duality motif suggests the
harvester is torn between multiple
identities at least one of whom has some
major cannibalistic tendencies which
sounds like he may have even linked with
the practice of catholic communion this
is some heavy stuff here and i cannot
wait to listen episode two listen to the
batman unburied podcast on spotify out
now follow me on instagram and twitter
at eavos follow new rockstars subscribe
to dark side for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
do
[Music]
you